and we better get ben simon in here
because i think i'm gonna lose my mind i
think i'm gonna lose my mind what's
going on here
you ready dude
i don't think everyone's ready for me
what are they saying out there about me
oh we're talking a lot of stuff i know i
know wow look at all these special
guests do you want to say hi it's a
marathon stream day
upstairs all right get upstairs
all right is this you
do you need me to help you out here let
me know yeah yeah so hey i saw you had a
co-host today do i get a co-host no i'm
not that entertaining
good what are you actually gonna do well
i was gonna put my job on the line
if we didn't get this these funds but
i've been told that we got the funds
yeah we got the funds so i can i can
live to work another day
that's good yeah
so uh
all right are you allowed to play
unrated games on this thing uh i would
never you can do whatever you need to do
though
well i'm gonna single-handedly
ruin the st louis chess club lead chess
account yeah i mean it's it's the
accumulation of all of our ratings
you're part of it so whatever
it's just kind of an average rating
accumulation of the damage here is a
calculator
in case you need to do some tough math
and here is a green screen in case you
need to do fireworks display so well i
don't know i know how to do math but
what's going on here what is this for
the fireworks but i showed bruh did you
see when i did it with brian no i missed
it no he was very impressed did you want
to see it yeah did you get the the the
is that when you got the yeah yeah you
want to see it it was actually he was
very impressed oh wow that's when
viewership spiked yeah yeah everybody
was watching yeah exactly um so let's go
we'll go here let me show you this and
we'll show we'll show chat this okay in
case they somehow didn't miss it this
was our incredible feat of the day oh
god no no no no no no oh god oh god you
got to watch the ad oh god oh god oh
all right let's go here
and it's one of our top clips now
all right here oh here we go
we are do you want to say hi to people
sure you know what i love is that a hot
pocket no oh here you you got to get in
the middle so make sure you somehow aim
at the camera it's rachel
hi
yeah hi guys
that is super cool
you know what
i love about you know as as we're
relaxing the rules a little bit for
broadcasting what i love is that it's
more of a party atmosphere it was no fun
when it's just one guy in here or one
girl in here we got to have the party
hey brian clark this was you brian clark
sent in the donation a very very
generous donation he fulfilled the
entire thing the wrestler
i don't know is he a wrestler brian
clark very famous wrestler i don't know
what he's doing but then so i had this
we we don't need any of this anymore no
uh
and then here here let me make this just
perfect for the twitch viewing audience
here
okay so this was it so brian clark thank
you so much i don't think you were here
when you missed this celebration
we completed our chess cops fundraiser
which we had actually started in may 1st
so this is really cool this is an epic
thing i hope people can uh can hear it
oh wait wait wait oh shoot
i can't believe your display
ugh who would use the ben simon display
when you can do it this way wait but now
i don't have my clip oh god
who would do it this way
oh god
this is rough man this is tough being a
streamer dude
here we go look at that people can see
it now so brian
uh thank you thank you so much i didn't
see it during the thing because i didn't
see the the paypal but we did it and you
will see
brian smith was very very impressed with
this firework display
i let him hit the button ready
you can tell he's trying to like hold in
he's trying to hold it in
he's shocked there are actually
fireworks behind him
he doesn't know he's speechless i say
that's really impressive huh and he's
just like yeah
yeah that's that's very he's trying to
like he's trying to keep up straight
face how loud the fire fire was
there's this big explosion dude
if you guys were talking it wouldn't be
able to hear you and then i tell him
that it's going to go on for another six
minutes and he's like oh god
that's what the people paid for like
with donations yeah
who cares about this right this is what
it's like paid for
and now he tells me after he just like
dissed my firework thing
oh you can keep it on during the thing i
say no you're kind of a party pooper
dude
called him a party pooper so that was it
that was how we we got it that's how we
decided to celebrate our uh our donation
so huge thanks to brian clark and
everybody else there's a lot of generous
people here today so
now how do i get your name to change
from that to my name all right you go
back here okay
and then you do this scene the way that
you do it oh i gotta do it over here no
you can have any scene you want but
that's
this one says jonathan scene do not
touch yeah so i should touch that one no
so and it looks a lot different so i'll
know immediately because it looks like
this yeah and
i just play the whole monitor so now you
can show if you want to show firework
clips this is the easiest way to do it
so
but then you usually use this one
the inferior one yes and i get the best
one well i always preferred this one
myself okay well then you're happy so
i'm going to give you the main seat i'm
going to get out of here okay i'm gonna
watch you for
30 minutes so how much money do i have
to earn uh zero dollars so you can go
right just you can just let loose dude
you can just fail talk about pro
wrestling you did this this was just for
the stream huh you actually you got up
you did you did this yeah i hadn't
shaved in like two weeks and so i was
like halfway there and i was like you
know what i'm just gonna leave the
mustache that's good no this is good
okay so i know you got something good
coming
i don't know what it is
but i'll leave you to it i can't wait to
see what it is
bye chat thanks brian thanks everybody
[Music]
there's cables everywhere
i tell you what
all right
i don't have anything prepared no one
tell him
all right
hello chess fans it's ben simon back
here on the platform
known as twitch
i can't believe it every time i think
it'll be the last time and it never is
well i was going to put my career on the
line today we were going to put it all
on the line
if we didn't get that last 100
or so for the chess cops fundraiser we
were going to be made liars up at the
gala everyone was going to laugh at us
you couldn't raise enough money what
kind of video department are you and i
was going to be thrown under the bus i'd
have to leave i'd have to skip town
catch the next jet out leave with brian
smith but thankfully
it didn't go down that way and we got
the money so thank you all so much and
the fireworks presentation was
spectacular
me audi conch shell chemist meowdi
indeed
and i think what i'm going to do is move
this microphone
over here so when i look at my comments
i don't talk away from you
okay
so
i haven't played chess in a couple of
weeks because when you work at the chess
club you don't play that much chess
it's
just a thing i don't know why it is how
it is but this is an analysis screen it
looks like so i'm going to go to uh
are we challenging here is that what's
happening
5-0
okay so i've got two challenges in i've
got a challenge from a 2000 rated player
and i've got a challenge from a sub 1000
and i'm gonna go with the sub 1000
because
there is an increment involved i i do
like increment i don't like this
uh five nothing you know that's that's
no good so here we are
by the numbers
the biggest day of cam
5751's life
for a
1400
rating differential here
now i've been talking about
walking
and talking
and how i'm not good at it in this case
walking is the plane
so as i strive to entertain you minions
i'll do my best
to not completely destroy the st louis
chess club account
and we're going to be together for quite
a while here
now
what's
what's the latency on this
because if i say a move
is this is this guy gonna know what i'm
talking about
knight takes all right see we're gonna
we're gonna double up on that knight on
c3
okay
how how do streamers do it yeah five
minutes plus three seconds that's okay
yeah
uh he gave me his queen
hooray
all i need is to get one good win to
start that's all i need
because there's going to be a lot of
pain
there's going to be a lot of pain until
6 central here okay
and it's probably going to be
on me
i like free pawns chomp chomp there it
is
as rja is waiting in the wings
to demolish an opponent that is by the
books 300 points stronger than he is or
she is
i guess i should use the they pronouns
for these because i don't know who you
people are
i don't know
we've had our fair share of uh
trolls around these parts as well in the
past
is usually these dudes pretending to be
women
online
so other guys will flirt with them it's
a very strange occurrence very strange i
don't know why you guys do that
but it's a thing
so i'm gonna try to stick with the days
all right so now i just got to wrap this
up right
get more players into the game
let's let's get this uh bishop out maybe
maybe that wasn't the best way to get
the bishop out
but you gotta start somewhere
see rja you say i am a male
how how can i believe you how can i
believe you man
i can't trust anyone out in these parts
it's the wild west of chess
now he moved the rook off the
uh a file
so now
i get my bishop out the right way i
wanted to see
works out
am i coming in okay for you guys the
audio levels are
the uh okay
i i talked to you over here but i talked
to you over here it's a little confusing
hooray that's like
one of
the only games i've won on lead chess
this year thank you cam 5751 thank you
for the game
and thank you for lifting my spirits
uh
legitimately for the beginning of this
next two hours okay so um
conch chess chemist has challenged me to
a game in ten but um
okay look
all right rja you want to beat up on me
you want to beat up on me 5'3
i told you the steps i have to accept
let's do it now this is where i could
use a co-host you know there's a whole
other seat right next to me i could use
a co-host right now so they could take
some of this talking heat away from me
and i could give you
a good shot
you guys remember perry coulson used to
stream for this channel he'd get really
into these games and he would just stop
talking and i feel like that's what i
need to do right about now is just stop
talking but i can't stop talking because
that's why i'm on twitch i have to talk
to you
you got to talk to the people you got to
play the people
all right
the raja
the raja
if you didn't pronounce his name before
you are now
i don't like any of this
there's probably a reason for that
you guys seen any good movies lately
i need to hold you off with a nice
question for a few moments
so tell me about your movies
oh
no yeah i don't like any of this
now in real life
i am
a
1500
classical us chess rated player
but i was once a 1766
rated urs player
which for those of you who don't know
is the greatest chess rating system
ever built
and
simultaneously the world's worst
marketed
chess rating system
but it really is uh it was after one
tournament i was 1766. it rates chess at
all time controls and even 960.
universalrating.com
uh we uh
hired the team who invented it but
if you really look into it it's
over a long run more accurate than the
elo system an improvement on the elo
system um
it unfortunately just doesn't have a lot
of traction traction right now i think
it's really something
okay so i'm gonna lose this bishop for a
night right
right
yeah
no
red notice is bad well red notice is
only on netflix right muck a luck
i watched uh survivor series i'm a big
pro wrestling guy i watched survivor
series on sunday and
wwe has a big co-promotion with red
notice and it was really annoying after
a while
[Laughter]
i had about enough
um
so it looks like i might be losing uh
both of these bishops eventually for an
exchange of uh the knights
conventional wisdom says that's not
pretty
unless i just don't move
the bishop on h7 right
night on the rim very good that's what
my chess teacher always told me
what's that sound
there's a zombie on the screen i don't
know what this means
looks like someone subscribed but it's
over the strategy across the board text
so it was hard to see
as far as i know we are experiencing a
zombie
invasion right here on twitch you're
seeing it first
elo system k-factor has a lot to
consider yeah the cool thing about
improved rating systems
that improves on the k factor for elo
is in elo
once you play enough games you are the
same level of active for the rest of
your chess career
and that's not right that shouldn't be
right
because
once
you are inactive let's say you don't
play for two years three years five
years at some point we don't know a lot
about your playing strength so that's
what rating systems like the urs and the
glicko uh
seek to fix
and that's why online
you don't see
uh
really any online gaming platform i see
uh
leecheschess.com like no one uses elo
they use a modified glico
but before the elo system there was the
harkness system
like rating systems are meant to be
improved upon you know it's it's like
science you know and tomorrow we will
know what we did not know today
it's not good guys this game is uh it's
not good i hope you're happy raja
makalux says i guess the rating system
discriminates against
mothers on
maternity breaks or
fathers on paternity breaks i yeah it's
you could consider a lot of things but
if you're away from the board we know
less about how you play that is the
bottom line
all right now my night comes
takes oh pre-move forgot about pre-moves
so my c is hanging
my time is dwindling
nothing looks good
my queen is just bad
look i could i could only accept sub
1000 challenges all day guys you know i
could do that
i'm trying to be a man of my word here
gotta protect that sea
gotta protect the sea
so does glyco i think uh discriminate
against
uh mothers on maternity breaks i guess
i'll read it like that
yeah like i said um
it could be someone who was in a car
accident and they're paralyzed they
can't play chess over the board
yes in a sense that would be
discrimination as well
it's just how it is if you're away from
the board
your rating is less stable that's how it
should be
and i'll tell you who has the most
unstable rating in the house is lm st
louis chess club on leachates
because we have about seven people
playing on this account and i may be the
very worst
and there's i'm just tied up in a
straight jacket right now look at this
i don't even know
i don't even know
children unless they are prodigies do
not leave much time to study chess yeah
i mean
yeah that's
legit uh you've seen players in the u.s
championship men and women alike who
have
if not given up the game then scaled
back their play because of their
families it is hard to
uh
to fit that all in there's only so many
minutes in the day
thank you e plus for your explanation
yeah zero sum game rating systems
game rating systems really
fascinating stuff i think
okay the dam's about to break guys so uh
well i just miscalculated
i thought i wanted that queen
off of the diagonal hitting my f pawn
the f7 pawn
but it still doesn't work
no doesn't work
one thing you may not know about me is i
play until mate
i don't like to run out of time i don't
like to resign
and this is the good thing for me in the
online era is this is considered
less obnoxious to some extent than doing
it over the board
go ahead
go ahead
so
we're not movie people here that's for
sure
no one likes any movies they just hate
red notice
okay
i saw the new
rocky iv the director's cut
that was pretty nifty
don't know if i like it more than the
original
but i think it certainly
accomplished everything it set out to do
making the movie more realistic
yeah much a luck i mean if they're gonna
sit on it then i'll just
leave the window open and walk away
myself
a funny notice actually a funny notice
funny story i uh
there was a gentleman who almost got
into a fight with me
uh years ago at the uh panera bread in
the del mar loop here in st louis which
is where people gathered to play chess
before the st louis chess club was
around
and uh this gentleman he's an older
russian fellow
and
um
he had me in a king and rook versus king
endgame
and
i didn't resign and it was blitz
and i kept playing on and he was
getting very frustrated
um
and it wasn't pretty um he had forgotten
how to checkmate with a rook
so
he didn't play me again
all right
good game raja
all right
how many people how many people are
watching 67 viewers man 67 that's pretty
good that's the most i've ever had
who's been watching this all day okay
which which one of you have been
watching this since 10 a.m central we
had this pirate you guys see this pirate
steve the pirate he came on here i've
seen this guy before
uh you know they claimed it was live but
i said how can a cartoon be live but it
was a it was a real
pirate like definitely not a puppet at
all
this this pirate uh was teaching chess
and would like lean over to the side
every now and then it was really weird
but uh i think he raised some money so
that that's that's pretty good
one thing kind of similarly
done
is i had mate and one in a position
and forced a draw instead
not for
not for bm or anything i'm just bad
and didn't see it the game still haunts
me to this day
yeah i think we've all had a lot of
situations like that conch shell chemist
i think a lot of a lot of situations
from my gateway chess league high school
days
just silly games you go back oh i'm
gonna look at my first game back when i
was 14
my first rated game and
what was i thinking i remembered they
were a lot better than they actually
were
throwing for content maybe
it's too it says 69
for me
throwing for content what do you mean
brian clark
what are you what are you talking about
i don't understand this doesn't have any
context here
yeah all of our viewer accounts are
slightly different
it's like that way on youtube as well
speaking of youtube tonight
at 6 30 p.m
central dorset derek shawnee will
continue
her series on
playing
against the sicilian
um that'll be on youtube
so be sure to check that out we'll be
doing that at 6 30 p.m central
which is two hours away
okay so let's take a look at some more
challenges here
we've got the conch
shell the cot the conch
conch chest chemist
five plus three
we've got a chess worm
otb
which is nick risco
and we've got robinson man
well conch i think has been waiting the
longest so i'm very intrigued by
robinson man
and by how chess worm wants to just kick
my butt and he knows he will so we'll
make him wait
koch let's do it game in five plus three
i'm black is everyone choosing white on
purpose or is that random what's going
on there
everyone just wants to give themselves
the benefit here
you know
hey what's going on there's another
zombie
someone subscribed
i don't like that zombie
i'm sure that i'm supposed to give you a
shout out when you subscribe
that makes subscribing worth it and i
understand however i legitimately cannot
see who subscribed
so i apologize mr zombie
i'm not exactly what you would call a
twitch guy
i can't oh i kind of wish i would have
moved my bishop out
um
along the ch diagonal
but i'm i'm probably still okay
no no chessworm otb i don't think
anyone's going to forget your real
identity
and your online
name
that's not a thing
no one will forget
knights on the rim very bright very
bright hey look at that it's caleb denby
chasing a chicken
you know that chicken chasing allowed
him to go on to defeat jonathan trance
in the match he was training for right
there
that's that was called all in we did
that in 2019.
turns out turns out being a serious
chess player like jonathan schwarz
doesn't always pay off
you
who do i favor
in the world championship match
well
jan napomischi versus magnus carlson i
think the opening ceremony was today in
dubai
and the first game begins in a couple of
days if i'm correct
um
well magnus
but um
i think it's it's a lot
slimmer than people might think okay
because classical chess
you're you're playing now 14
14 classical games in regulation not 12
but last time fabiano and magnus played
12 draws in a row and it came down to
rapid a rapid play-off
and fabi lost all three because magnus
is clearly the better rapid player
whereas in classical they're very even
when you're talking about classical
chess
i
mean a lot could happen you know this
could go 14 draws in a row
and then you know and one win one win in
regulation is a huge advantage to a
player
you might remember uh back in 2016
karjakin and carlson karjakin was up a
point in new york city
and people were like i don't know if
carlson come back
it's just one point
but it's so hard to get a win in
regulation carlson did come back
and he did win that title defense
but yeah i'll be watching that's for
sure
i was thinking about going to the match
um i gone to the last couple of matches
but um the prices to dubai from saint
louis are
pretty outrageous
decided to be
smarter to watch this one online
i too remember when ken west was up a
pawn once
this is
dangerous this is bad this is real bad
so uh when i first started playing at
the chess club i was coming in with my
high school rating which was like
1100 it wasn't anything too impressive
and the first guy that i played in this
club regularly
was ken west
and ken west was around 1300 and i was
like if i can knock off ken west
this he this will be my first stepping
stone to getting to like 1500 or
something
and um eventually i did i was very proud
of myself so ken west is very
self-deprecating and he's a great guy
though
i always like playing chess with him
blitz you know give him a little bit of
a longer time control so he can put up a
fight you know it's like me walking and
talking in these games
it doesn't always end up the best
uh man
does that work
discover attack
double attack
there's got to be a way out
am i missing something why did that just
happen
was that the only way out
might have been the only way out
i can't analyze my own moves
what do you think this is
i have to talk to you guys
nick says there was like totally a mate
on me
on him
nick says yes i don't know what that
means i ask questions for both
this is it man
this is it
very bright night on the rim
situation looks a little grim
joe bruno ben i shook your hand the
other night did you know it was me yes i
did joe at the pizza party
and it was good to see you
hmm
okay
well i i can i can wriggle out of czech
mates okay
i can be a bit of a chess worm myself
what pizza did i have
um i don't know it wasn't very good
actually
if i can win this pardon me and pardon
me i gotta go into perry coulson mode
here because
uh if i can win this i'm gonna be a very
happy person
look at that
look at that work
yeah look at that double pin
two pins
on the conch
chess chemist
i want to get the most for my money i
had to take that b pawn
had to take the b pawn
oh my gosh
am i nervous
a little bit
no no no no leave it leave it right
there okay i hate i hate the lee chest
sounds dude like okay look i have i have
an increment okay everyone just chill
out for a second just chill out
this game is everything to me man
this is everything
gotta win this game
don't blunder this queen
don't blunder the queen don't don't even
give away pawns
just don't do it
all right
oh my god
oh my god
all right see this is why i need
increment okay i don't like these these
these buzzer embarrassments okay i don't
need this in my life i don't need any
buzzer embarrassments i got this okay
i've still got this
just get back in the corner okay just
just get
get
no no no no no no
no stalemates
no
stalemates
my goodness
yes
yes there's no way out conch chess
chemist
there's no way out
all right
joe bruno have we not met before the
pizza party unbelievable
um
good game conch chess chemist is that
you mino kawik ram singh he
in the chat he's conch
shell chemist
and
in leeches they're kant's chess chemist
i have a bad habit of blundering my
queen whenever i play this account it
seems well that's because the account is
cursed and you should create another one
okay
so
it's been a great time so far uh with
you movie hating folks here on twitch
thanks for your donations today if
indeed you did give we needed that last
100 to not have egg on our face at the
gala for failing to complete the
fundraiser you know it's a lot similar
to uh public radio community radio when
they do the drives you know you gotta
you gotta fulfill the drive
to keep the lights on but actually it
wasn't for us these lights are staying
on it was for the chess cops program
which is a great program and we're
having our next event for that on
december 10th
i know because i'm going there to
shoot it for video
yeah conch shell uh it looks like you
did have mate in three as well
uh cry emoji all the way home
because
close but no cigar
who's up next
we have the chess worm over the board
who wants to play a game that's not over
the board
and the robinson man
mr risco
you'll have to wait
robinson man is white
this is a five
uh oh my
this is a 5 8
game
you give me the king's gambit i must
accept
it's the rule of the game isn't it
what do i do now
says brian clark yes
the botez sisters what about them is
there some some inside joke i'm not
understanding
botes
uh
am i in a good position or am i just
falling into a really dastardly trap
it's tough to tell
the botez gambit uh okay
man auto mod is all over this stuff
auto mod
i don't know if people can see the auto
mod so i won't repeat what the auto mod
just did but it's all over
it's all over these things now
this rook up here
this rook isn't looking very kind
lame
lame
the botes gambit oh sacrificing the
queen
in an unsound manner okay
so it's not actually a gamut it's a it's
a joke right it's a meme it's a funny
image we can put words on top of and
share it on reddit to our friends right
it doesn't have an eco code is that what
you're saying
this is this is just horrible
this is just
horrible
how am i going to move the queen though
in time shadow walker the king was
behind it
uh i'm just one move too late and uh
that's my loss
wait
well
wait now
now can't i be at least okay
did robinson man miss robinson man's
shot
well yeah shadow walker uh if we go far
enough back to when i wasn't a complete
[ __ ] i probably could have done that
that's true
so what do you guys like to do in your
spare time do you just like chess is
that all you guys do just play chess all
the time
i mean
what are we doing here you know
like you guys don't like movies
okay
does anyone like wrestling i mean if you
don't like wrestling what are you even
doing
boxing you guys like team sports who
likes team sports
oh my gosh
should i take the pawn
is it poisoned
it's probably poisoned
maybe i'll take this one yes
i can take the b one later yes
cool people play chess even cooler
people watch people play chess
on twitch
that seems to be the consensus
the people have
spoken how much damage can i do with
just
a queen out there and nothing else
developed huh
[Music]
all right
all right
i don't like that bishop down there
get out of the house
get out of the house i'm i'm sick of you
hanging around here like a spider okay
just leave
gonna need this bishop out of there
joe bruno says why are my messages being
moderated i don't know joe bruno maybe
you have a potty mouth
this this auto mod is pretty strict i'll
tell you that
it's uh
but can i even oh i think i can do it
all right your message was held for
swearing
i'm going to allow it
because i i don't think i don't think
crappy is a bad word gonna allow it yeah
yeah
you're lucky this time joe bruno
giving you the break
all right well this
free pawn fallacy
has proven to be just that
gotta retreat just a little bit oh yeah
joe bruno you gotta be more careful
oh my gosh brian clark you're so try
you're so true
to think of the children
we gotta save the children
all of the hundreds of them watching
this twitch broadcast
on their ipads
[Laughter]
so luca
luca just tried a work around
uh
the auto mod and the auto mod got him
too
well if i have time i'll i'll fix you up
luca man that auto mod is brutal
what a brute
the auto mod
stricter than youtube
yes sir
my queen's running out of spaces
yeah and i don't think it's going to
stop anytime soon unfortunately
i hope that robinson man doesn't bully
my queen around
what's a bit why are people talking in
bits
what what what what is this like a uh is
this a
is this something new on the blockchain
okay
man robinson man is about to huff and
puff uh and blow the side of this house
in
building up quite the formidable force
here
i don't feel like i'm losing but i feel
like i could be losing
uh sooner rather than later bit is fake
twitch currency that people use to
donate real money ah okay i hate 2021. i
hate all of it just take it all back
okay this is too much to remember we'll
just get one
maybe two online video platforms okay
we're gonna use usd or great british
pounds or whatever your local currency
is just everyone just stop okay everyone
just calm down
nick i fear what i do not understand
if i take that bishop there's pain
coming
or wait
yeah there's pain coming
this might be the beginning of the end
the queen harassment was just too much
costly coyote you know i'm not really
sure i think my u.s chess rating is
around
1450 standard
it's been a while
but us chess elo says i'm as active as
i've ever been
so
that's my rating
oh
oh
mm-hmm
oh my god
all right here we go
into the dogfight hey maurice smashley
do i like this no
now i do
okay
home stretch robinson man i know you're
crying your eyes out right now and
rightfully so that was pretty bad you
know that blunder could ruin someone's
night
but i still have to close this deal
i'm feeling pretty good about it your
moves are kind of limited
i think it's
it's a little bit late
to call it the botez gambit wouldn't you
say i mean we're on move 26
uh conch shell chemist i was 1766
in the urs
so that's the one i want to cite
but it's inactive because i hadn't
played a feta rated tournament since
uh december 2017.
is this mate am i going to do something
silly
yes
all right thank you luca and good game
robinson man
wherever you
are
nick risco says think of the botes
gambit more of a tactical motif instead
of an opening
okay
uh brad's uh look
we've been trying to do this for a long
time
you know lee chess is tough to copy do a
floppy
uh i feel your pain
i salute you
botez gambit
not an opening rather a lifestyle
the sewer squirrel
has issued a challenge well i don't know
sewer squirrel let's look at the
candidates we have
a chess worm over the board
wanting to play an online game
and we have the sewer squirrel
now look we gotta make the best decision
for business here and i gotta know who's
gonna be sticking around and i know that
that chest worm over the board that's
actually online has been sticking around
so you know what
chest form over the board
i'm gonna have to wait a little bit
longer
i'm white
thank you sewer squirrel you're so
generous
no look i want to tell you something
nick
you don't throw the main event on in the
middle of the card okay you gotta wait
you gotta let it build
to
a crashing
pinnacle
a stunning
crescendo
a game that the people will pay to see
and that's me and you nick
that's me and you
don't put this on in the middle of the
card
plus
does it
sewer squirrel pique your interest
there are no squirrels in the sewer
and if they are
they almost certainly don't want to be
there
this is a player in need
we gotta help this player
this player this players
needs a little bit of help here
have any tricks
the best trick of all
the chess from over the board look
man nick come on
we waited three years
for mayweather pacquiao three years okay
if they waited three years you can wait
a little bit longer
okay i'm mayweather
and you're pacquiao
they did wait a little too long i will
say
wasn't that great
they were just
about six months
past their primes
do i regret what has happened so far
maybe
who is it
oh it's emily are you coming to be my
co-host
we had co-hosts earlier today
it's a new day it's 2019 once again we
can sit next to each other play chess
and harass the opponent
thank you
bye then have fun bye-bye
come back if you change your mind
i prefer to get my squirrels from
chocolate factories though they're tough
to get
i don't know what that means
don't write me off yet okay
don't do it
sorry
perry coulson mode i gotta concentrate
okay i can't be talking to you people
all the time okay
you'll understand certainly
take
take is more effective
when you state it
it's not required
by the rules of chess but
it's just more effective
it's like slamming down the piece hey
who's that
it's a zombie
but i don't know i don't know who that
is i i don't know because the the green
name is over the watch it says watch and
i i can't tell what it said so i
appreciate you subscribing mr zombie mrs
zombie
uh neutral zombie
but i just don't know who you are
much appreciated
should i take
yeah
yeah
just take it back just take the pawn
back god
why you have to do like that
why did you have to do like that
oh my gosh what's gonna happen here
what's gonna happen here this this is
just impossible to calculate guys i
don't know
no one no one can see this
so
oh oh
all right so do i promote
an exchange do i
take the knight
this is this is worth some
some calculation right
so like i i gotta i gotta take the
knight right
i hope
this auto mod oh my gosh
oh my gosh auto mod you are outrageous
held the message
uh from nick's too quick
says that the message is
a sex based term
the message is bishop c7 is winning
nick's too quick never say things like
that again that is entirely
inappropriate okay
this is a chess stream get out of the
gutter
besides we're in the sewer we have no
time for the gutter
we're here with the sewer squirrel
all right so do i just promote the pawn
or do i play bishop c7 well that
inappropriate message advises i play
bishop c7 so i feel like if i play
bishop c7 i'm kind of cheating because i
i have had a convincer tell me this now
i see right now that bishop c7
is a destroyer of a move
so what's what's more important to me
my integrity or
me winning this game
he never said anything the auto mod
caught it no one saw that
no one saw that
all right so uh the sewer squirrel is in
some dire straits right now but he has
some time
they have some time because we
uh
have an eight-second increment
it's like forever
it's fine
it's fine
take
take
that's an auto promotion i don't want
any of these auto promotion going on how
do i turn auto promotion off that's
dangerous
that's dangerous
i really don't know how to turn that off
usually there's like a little control
panel here
i know my queen is hanging don't you
worry i know that queen is hanging and i
know i could probably have gotten more
for that but now i'm worried about this
i don't do not want to be screwed over
by an auto promoter okay ben get your
head in the game
we can worry about auto promote later
after this game we're tackling it this
is a serious issue
yeah you know it's stalemate city okay
you think you want a queen and all of a
sudden stalemate
and you have
egg on your face
uh nick's too quick says press control
while promoting thank you
i'll have to keep that in mind i still
want to turn it off but that is a good
thing to know
hold down control while promoting
do i have some kind of fancy checkmate
here before i just take the rook
i feel like i should in the middle of
the board these questions are rhetorical
i'm not asking you to help me cheat okay
this is not our job to to gang up on the
sewer squirrel
just thought you should know
no tricks
i ain't switching
we've been doing this thing for over an
hour i can't believe it
seems like an eternity
don't lose on time thank you abraham
thank you
i will do my best
i will checkmate
in the next move
thank you
good game sewer squirrel i hope you find
your way out of the sewer one of these
days i'm back into the tree
with a nut that's where you belong
ben why aren't you performing more often
for the public says derrick meadows well
derek look
the price has got to be right this is
the same reason why nick risco and i
can't be made right now okay we've got
to let the anticipation build we got to
make sure that the dollars and cents are
correct we got to make sure the venue is
right we got to make sure that people
get the coffee on time and a nice slice
of cake right before you go on the air
this has got to happen you know this is
this is why this is why i don't go on
all the time this it was last night
jonathan schwarz called me up and he
said
ben we need you
we are down we're down a lot of money we
got to get this chess cops fundraiser
going
so at the gala we can brag about how
great of fundraisers we are and i said
you didn't close on that chess cops
fundraiser yet and he said no and i said
well that is an emergency and i i thank
you for for bringing out the big guns
now
thankfully earlier today
steve the pirate whoever that is
jonathan and grandmaster brian smith
closed the deal and as you could see
earlier the fireworks show was amazing
grandmaster brian smith absolutely loved
it he had never seen anything as great
in his entire life
allegedly and we got the money we got
the money and so um i'm not going to say
that i'm only brought in
uh
in emergency situations
but you know they know who to call
i have heard rumors about ben simon's
writer what does that mean what are you
talking about brian clark i don't know
what that means
they were very good fireworks i agree
uh
a costly coyote yeah that's the sewer
squirrel
no no no look the path to victory sewer
is not always through me
just get out of the sewer
all right who's next we got the chest
worm over the board
looking for an online game
and we've got nick p12
who wants a game in three
no delay
no increment
he's rated
21.50
is there really no one else who's gonna
challenge me right now is there really
no one else who's going to challenge the
st louis chess club on lee chess i mean
come on
we're going to unleash the main event
right now because i'm not gonna play a
game in three
against nick p12 oh hey
hey look at that
i'm feeling charitable
what is this what is this
you tricked me
all right
all right sewer you stay in the sewer
you you tried to pull the the dipsy
doodle on me it's an old-timey chess
move where you know you challenge
someone into a game and the clock's set
to a different time okay game in 15
seconds no delay no increment you know
you know what i'm gonna tell you what
i'm just
i'm so upset right i cannot believe it i
cannot believe it sewer squirrel
sewer squirrel
i've regained my composure but sewer
squirrel
you stay down there you stay down for a
while and you think about what you just
did
and you chew on that loss i just gave
you okay i beat you at your own game
sewer squirrel
okay
huh
never before i that is insulting
anyway
oh my god
you see i want to tell you i don't know
how to get this on the screen right now
but this this squirrel this squirrel has
just challenged me again
to a game
in one second
no
no
no sewer
it's over
it's over
okay
it's over
all right up next
get some real players we got the conch
chess chemist
we've got nick p12
who wants to kick my butt in a three
plus three
and we've got the chest worm over the
board
once an online game
so uh
let's uh
okay okay okay okay nick nick
nick risco stop
stop
i understand okay i know okay he's
pulling out he's pulling out
this is it mayweather pacquiao everyone
it's me and nick risco one on one
there's no way he's ever beaten me
hopefully he has to go even faster than
he thinks so he has to resign
man i am not scared of anybody next too
quick now if you're confused because
there's so many nicks you should be
because there are
grand total of two nicks
involved
there's been kind of a theme today
i guess i don't like my bishops huh
oh my gosh oh that was that a good move
probably not
oh my god
hey look
even the greats get caught by a big shot
in the first round sometimes okay
doesn't mean it's over
just usually
this is it guys this is uh i mean we'll
play games after this but this is uh
this is what the people came to see
people are paying 29.95 to watch this on
in-demand pay-per-view right now
okay this is serious business
and i just have nothing
i have nothing
all right sewer squirrel sewer squirrel
apologizes you know what
i'm not ready
to forgive you sewer squirrel but i will
take it under consideration i appreciate
the apology but it's not accepted yet
okay
what are my options trade everything
trade everything trade everything and
i'm still losing
what do i have i have nothing
i have nothing
i don't want to trade
what do you think of that what do you
think of that risco
do you think
gotta start watching the clock i mean
i have some leeway here but
uh i have sunk below a minute
i just love games with increment because
you don't have to get into a mindless
scramble at the end you just have to
stay on top of the moves have a pace
and keep with it
i just i don't like holding onto that
bishop anymore it's just all
i hate trading it off but
i just feel like i'm babysitting it
hey nick look i'm gonna tell you i'm
gonna talk straight to you nick risco um
you know what's on the line here right i
mean like
yeah you're winning
but do you really want to sync the club
account i know you play on this too
i know i think it's best that we just
call the whole
thing off
a gentleman's draw no no a no contest
we'll throw it out no ratings change
it's great we'll shake hands and just
act like it never happened what do you
think
i got that scary leech s sound i don't
know if that came across on the show but
um that is a very scary sound
i look like i'm making a really cool
attack don't i
yeah
really cool
it's a great looking attack
just all up in there
all up in that space
black's just powerless you know
he might
want to draw
i'm just saying like it's in his best
interest i'm just looking out for nick
it'd be embarrassing to lose this
i mean the night is on the rim it's very
grim it's running for its life
what can be done
what can be done
what can be done what can be done
oh my gosh
i don't
know the knicks are gonna rub it in
no
no
no g2 for you
oh god
oh my god
oh no
perry coulson mode
no shame no regrets
uh
it's bad it's bad
prognosis is bad
well why do the fans come to see
they don't want to see a decision
they want to see
the knockout i guess i'll give it to
them
good game nick risco
i'll enjoy our 60 40 split
well enough
purse i'm talking about the purse the
price fund big money coming in on that
one
okay
so that's what we came to see
uh what do we have still to come uh
show's not over we still have some time
but i do want to put over that we have
at 6 30 tonight dorset derek shinee
continuing her series just in psychology
the series is how to play against
the sicilian i think this is part four
tonight if you want to check out the
other three parts after the show you can
do that it's all on youtube and we will
be live at 6 30 central time to do part
four tonight with dorsa she'll have the
chat open and active as always let's get
over 100 viewers tonight what do you say
uh okay
so i guess uh
i guess nick has had his fun i get get
out of here nick get out get out of here
nicarisco
i thought you had to be somewhere
all right what do we have next we have
oh a new name we have the conch chess
chemist
let me play we have
nick
p1233
um
do i go into that one again
we have the sewer squirrel
who has challenged me to a game in three
seconds
now if i look at this quickly enough
this game in three seconds looks like a
game in three minutes
not this time squirrel
it looks like we're gonna have to go
with ck lust
a gaming three
this monster is rated twenty four
hundred
all right guys this auto mod is out of
control i mean what what are we what are
we doing here auto mod has held another
message
due to it being a
er including sex based terms
it's knicks too quick
he says
you got one more nick
what's the algorithm for this thing who
invented this
just take random messages and
i don't know
all right
let's do uh ck lust this is gonna be a
quick one game in three
at least he's rated higher
i kind of hoped he wouldn't pick up the
phone but he did he picked up the phone
he's playing some crazy f six oh no this
is
he just doesn't even care he's just
throwing pieces at me
the the these get these games are the
worst because the opening is just so so
wild and out of control and then you
still lose
you're still going to lose and you know
it
and you can't do anything about it
and i got to remember
this is no delay
this is no increment
easy to forget
when you've been playing such a variety
as i have
this afternoon
should i be scared should i be scared
everyone's making noises in the other
room but i don't know if they're
actually looking at my game or not
oh that's not good
that might not be too good either
all right no delay no argument come on
ben come on what are you doing
because we don't think we don't think in
this game we just move
we just move
pre-move you see that
i pre-moved i never do that that means
i'm extra dangerous
are you scared ck lust are you scared
yet
shaking
terrified
petrified
stupefied
shhh
oh my god
when you think you have options
and then you don't have options
it can kind of mess you up a little bit
i didn't have a lot of options
it's like this guy knows what he's doing
and see now with no increment it's just
like silly moves
just pre-move everywhere
good one ck lust good one
conch shell chemist says everyone knows
that to escape a crocodile you have to
zig and zag but little known fact to
beat one at chess you must instead
zug and zwang
zvong zwang i think in the course of the
joke i'm supposed to say zwang
i'm a little disturbed that sounds like
a joke i would have made
a costly coyote also known as the sewer
rat says i always make sure to knock
before opening the fridge just in case
there's a salad dressing inside thank
you and so
we've been talking about that all
afternoon and uh i enjoy such topical uh
insights
okay
so we still have a conch chest chemist
and we have nick p12 uh i think i think
conch chess is probably my favorite
opponent of the day because surprise or
equally me equally matched
uh it's appreciated
if any is anyone uh in the chat coming
to the club to play in the uh
thanksgiving open this weekend
uh it's our biggest tournament of the
biggest open tournament of the year and
it's uh
we're back we're back for the first time
since 2019. i think we had an online
thanksgiving open last year um
come on let's be real you can't have a
classical uh open tournament like the
thanksgiving open online just didn't
work and i think there was some
controversy too like i think there was
some uh
rules violations if you get my drift
um
but in person that's where it's at man
i'm glad that we can have this back uh
st louis chess club st louis
chessclub.org that is for details on the
thanksgiving open
snarks you may be surprised to find out
that i don't really ever wear a mustache
this is a today kind of thing but thank
you i'm going to take that as a
compliment it's the only way that i can
even more danger says want to play
30 seconds with a one minute increment
uh it's a very mike comer-esque time
control of you i
uh how much would that be that's
is that a classical game
basically
is that a classical time control because
you make six average of 60 moves 60
moves judged in a game
yeah that'd be uh
it could be a two hour game right
no no yeah yeah two hour game
i must decline
oh 30 seconds or one minute
uh
bullet no no no no thank you
yeah let's do it yeah let's do it come
on
get in here one minute
come on
even more danger
i'm gonna tell you this
this sewer rat
has just challenged me to a game in
three minutes
no delay no increment
like the sewer rat is on the level
okay
no
i'm not ready sewer rat
i'm not ready
all right uh i'm
yeah but it uh you challenge me to the
minute and uh
uh okay here we go after this conch
chess me and you
so here's a minute with uh ck lust
he could be watching my screen to see
what my first move is going to be right
so
this is like
do people really talk when they're
playing bullet i mean what what are we
doing here
you know
what
are we doing
hell
oh my gosh
and then you just don't even see the
rook hanging in the corner i was like am
i gonna am i gonna mate him am i gonna
mate him right here no i'm not gonna
made him i'm gonna get made of myself or
i'm gonna lose on time come on yeah it's
over i'm glad i'm actually really glad
though that i got made it and uh with
time to spare i hate losing on time i
cannot stand it
even if it's just one minute nick's too
quick says am i invisible what's going
on uh
who are you again nick are you nick p12
no i just don't like i don't like gaming
one nick i don't like gaming one
um
yeah i know i just played a game in one
okay that was a special request i hate
gaming one
conch as promised here we go
conch chess chemist
known in the chat is conch
shell
chemist
if it's conch
it's this person
liberated toaster says how can i
challenge you to a game
on leaches.org
we are
st louis chess club that's all spelled
out that's the name of our account
challenge us st louis chess club on
leaches.org
conch chess where are you from
um
i assume somewhere with conch
shells right
oh he's
he's from somewhere not good
he's from the depths
yeah
yeah
yeah i know your game con's chess
chemist
oh my god
all right
okay yeah no it's it's okay that i don't
have a knight
to put on uh
c3 anymore
that's perfectly fine
kind of prefer it that way yeah
yeah
nothing wrong here nothing to see
nothing to see
everything is a
okay
no problems
i love being down four points of
material
conch shell says
i'm from pennsylvania so no cot shells
the original inspiration came from the
magic conch from spongebob squarepants
well i love that
that's really great
my favorite episode of spongebob was
uh i think it was from the first season
the one where um
they got stuck in
rock bottom
and they tried to catch the
the bus home and uh
hilarity ensued
is the best way to get this queen off my
back
to offer a queen trade i don't think
he's going to take the queen trait
because of
my b-pawn
maybe if i go here
is this what we call
groveling
groveling for a queen trade
because that's what i feel like i am
doing
successful gravel
everything is awful everything is awful
uh this my e-pawn is weak it's uh
it's not good i am
i am hoping that there is a big blunder
coming my way
i need one
uh no doubt
i need one
bad bad bad
this is what i call a
a babysitting experience this pawn on e
is uh an infant it is helpless
it needs to be babysat
um
but i don't know if it has much of a
future
i don't i don't know
and so
i have to go into more important things
snark says i challenged and i'm very
good at blundering well that you make a
good
you make a good argument there let me
tell you snarks that is a really strong
argument
that i should
uh play you
what
let's get back in this game okay let's
get back in this game come on ben
because you you you got a shot in you
got a shot
it's tough though tough opponent um
the the rat asked
do you actually get upset when i pulled
that dipsy doodle
you think i'm acting
ridiculous
sewer cat you know what just just go
somewhere else
now speaking of dipsy doodles um
what do i do
what do i what do i do here
seems like a logical move
that's scary we have a past pawn on the
run
and can i even stop it
do i have to sack right now
oh my
gosh i think i have to sack my friends
that is uh
oh
oh no
this is just extra bad isn't it
that's extra i don't want to get mated
may not be ending this uh
coming to the end of the session here on
a very s
strong note
not looking promising guys
i see it
i see it
that old discover check
taking my rook
can't happen can't happen today
it cannot happen today
sewaret says i'm challenged a challenge
and i'm very good at acting like i'm
from the sewers
that involves dipsy doodles blunders and
timeouts
you're a method actor is what you're
saying huh
you tell me you're not actually a
squirrel
how many levels
to this deception are there
sewer squirrel
how many levels
i think this uh is this it
is this the end of the line
i guess i'll play the uh
computer moves
when i think the computer moves will be
ah
just enough to make me think about it
huh conch
just enough to make me think about it
oh my gosh
just make it quick and painless okay
quick and painless
i plead
anything but
anything but
quick and painless
oh i still have that increment
perpetually two moves away from mate
losing that is
oh
my gosh
oh my gosh
i'm putting conch to work here guys
no no i'm not making fun of you coach
it's i i don't resign like ever so uh
you know gotta do what i gotta do you
know
if you give me an inch
i'll take a mile
did i miss a draw guys oh my gosh
good job conch
good game
had me on the edge of my seat for a long
time
well guys uh i am
done i'm done i'm through i'm through
with all of you okay we've had some good
times we've had some bad times we had
sewer squirrel but you know what in the
end we all learned a little bit
and before i even got in the room we
completed the chess cops fundraiser this
is what brought us to the dance and uh
it's been a real great time now i don't
know if i'm gonna be a regular here on
twitch probably not
uh the auto mod is really a buzz kill
but
uh you don't know
you don't know and uh
conch just says don't
look at the computer analysis oh don't
you worry koch i certainly won't i don't
want to know of the brilliant draw that
i had missed i feel like it was within
reach
and it is gone
what's that sound
what happened
chess weeb is rating us
um
just in time for us to go off the air
well
how does that happen
how do we what would where we go from
here i mean we've got like
100 people coming in or something like
that
i mean i don't see it yet
anyway uh i'm going to uh tell you one
last time we've got
about a half hour away from here 6 30
central time dorset derek shawnee on how
to play against the sicilian part 4
on
youtube so head on over there for 6 30
that will populate as we get get closer
um
i'm not going to end this stream yet
because we've got
89 viewers that just came in
from chessweeb
but i'm done i'm done there's nothing
more to be said
how do we raid someone else you know i
always thought that raiding was a funny
thing on twitch because
it sounds like you're taking from
someone but you're actually
giving it's a charitable
donation you're donating your audience
to another
streamer i don't understand i don't
understand why they call it rating it
sounds like a bad thing
according to the new twitch terms of
service a raid requires the streamer to
keep going for 30 more minutes is that
right zorom is that right because i
don't remember ever agreeing to that
okay
that doesn't sound right
all right guys to be real
uh here's why i can't stick around uh
you know that that youtube stream i was
telling you about with dorsa in in half
an hour
i'm actually the one who sets that up so
like i've got to set it up because if i
don't set it up there there actually
won't be a stream in a half hour
so
i think we've got this on in the other
room and so if if jonathan
or danny
or steve the pirate
or tracy
or
holden
or
oh the door is open it's jonathan
jonathan is back to relieve me we just
got a big raid from the chesapeake
yeah welcome back all right so who are
you gonna raid well i don't know how to
do it you don't know how to raise no i
don't can we just give it back to chess
we've just read him back no we can't
give it back to him oh okay now we took
it so we rated it like that's ours now
we took that yes okay we just definitely
took it so you go here
all right you click this button here
then you pick your favorite one of these
streamers
what if i don't like any of them
uh
you know
you'll feel like somebody like that
person this person who do you like let
me see
this family-friendly
uh levi uh levi's pretty good right levy
resman
we can do it if you want yeah is that
what you want to do yeah let's do it all
right wait he doesn't he doesn't need us
he has like a million right yeah sure
he's got he's got one million viewers
right now
now he has three and a half thousand
okay
uh
or if you don't know you can ask these
people all right but find somebody okay
because they're just powerless to go
anywhere else on their own
so
we got to send them somewhere well
somebody that we respect and trust so
this is a big responsibility okay they
are trusting us to send them somewhere
they want to be can we send them to a
hot tub stream no oh okay
uh
well let's let's uh yeah gotham's pretty
good let's i like him backslash raid
oh my gosh
here yeah backslash raid
i've never even done a backslash i've
never done a backslash i just forward
slash that does look like a forward
slash this is not gonna work no that's a
backslash
that is a backslash i swear that is a
backslash and then space his name
is it case sensitive
that's great now hit chat chat beautiful
if you did it right with the right kind
of slash are you sure yeah it's a
forward slash look you all saw this it's
a forward slash the other slash
yeah you're one of those weird
backslashes forward slash then you have
to like justify it because they're gonna
say no not levy for some reason
and then you're gonna have to justify
why you're doing it anyway despite
whatever they say
there yeah yeah so all right now do it
see look they're like no look that guy
says no that guy says now they're really
mad at you oh oh god so now you gotta
you better justify that dude
okay
uh he's oh that guy's really mad cool is
that a good justification he's cool yeah
sure that's a good justification i mean
you're making a horrible decision but i
mean we'll see what happens yeah let's
let's let's see how it turns out all
right make sure that make sure you get
at least 69 viewers
and then uh somebody's calling me and
then hit end stream and then raid now
whenever you're ready say bye though say
bye hey uh bye and uh enjoy gotham chess
he's pretty cool and he's gonna make
grand masters someday yes